sometimes you have to let go of people
that are driving you uh not driving you
forward and then holding you back um
letting go of mistakes you've made
because it happens in just a second ago
i was talking about those decisions and
most of the time you know what the right
decision is and maybe if you think you
know what it's not going to be the right
decision all the time right so you're
going to have to eventually be able to
you know
own your mistakes and let go
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're going
to be talking to assaf shamley the
co-founder and ceo of browzy but we're
not going to be spending much time
talking about browsing because we have
some really interesting insights from
assaf about his own journey as a leader
what it means to him to be a manager to
lead this company to grow as a leader
on less than 30 years old it's a pretty
awesome
discussion and i hope you enjoy asaf is
a results driven product director with
an agile approach to develop deliver and
market amazing products
with a technological background and
passion for cutting-edge technology he
can lead a startup company to a winning
product and that's exactly what he's
doing with browsing
with direct and immediate relations with
clients it enabled him to conceive ideas
on new products to provide better value
to clients and create new and winning
products and features to generate new
revenue streams and a better world
meet asaf
asaf welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you so much for being here how are you
i'm i'm very good thank you so much for
having me i'm very excited to be here
hey i'm assuming you're joining me from
the browsy offices right
i am i am johnny from the browser
offices here in the room with guy in tel
aviv you also have offices in new york
in japan as well i'm very excited wow
here
phenomenal and you know you're looking
at you know the the new world of content
publishers
creator economy and the way that
software is not just eating the world
but it's also eating the content world
and and so i'm excited to learn a little
bit about browsing about your own
background and why don't we start a
little bit about you know browsing what
is it that you do and and then we'll
dive into a little bit more of a soft
and your current position and and
thinking process
yeah of course um so browse the very
very
high level we are about 50 people uh as
i mentioned in tel aviv in indonesia
area actually in new york and in japan
uh overall 50 people um we started in
2017 um we are growing very rapidly over
the past uh year and so um we grew about
100 in employees and revenue as well in
just last year so we're very excited
about that um browsing is an ai company
aiming to help uh digital digital
publishers to improve their um their
user experience
and improving their uh online
advertising revenues the way that we are
doing that is by tailoring a specific
experience to each and every user uh in
in their content experience on the web
so if you're michael and i were both
very different people we're reading and
consuming content very very differently
browse is here to help publishers
maintain a very unique experience for
each and every one of those users
because you might be a very fast reader
i'm a very slow reader so we need to get
different experiences so what browser is
doing at the moment is taking the number
of ads per page and changing them for
you and for me and taking the locations
of the ad when they're loading those ads
on the page to make sure that you're
enjoying your experience as much as
possible and also the publisher can make
and guarantee higher revenue by adopting
the experience one of the key things the
browser we're saying is that everything
that we're doing nowadays is
personalized because you're going to get
an ad for a couch because you're on the
market for a new couch i'm gonna get an
ad for um a car because i'm on the
market for a car but the ad location
when it's gonna load uh where it's gonna
be on the page it's gonna be the same
for you and it doesn't make any sense
because nothing else is the same for you
and i because we're different users um
and this is the premise of what browser
is doing we're just doing that for
publishers right now but we're planning
to launch many other um verticals by uh
this year next year e-commerce and more
um in our future
how did you get into this space it's a
it's a really the whole personalization
space is is incredible and i think that
it's worth
a lot of people to to stop for a second
and rethink about what is our sort of
human computer interaction i know that a
lot of the a lot of ad tech companies
get a lot of hate for for you know
simply being in the attack space but the
truth is that you know you're giving you
taken as consumers you know within in
the information and the ai age um
there's quite a few positives rather
than negatives in a lot of these
endeavors and so it's a it's interesting
for me always how people get into into
these worlds and how you're thinking
about it
so i i agree i think that like anything
else it was my mistake it wasn't my uh
my intention to to reach that to to do
this what i do i started um so my
personal journey we could maybe get to
that later but um we started as a
company that does um ad attack we
thought very very differently and one of
our first first clients were hearst
media in the u.s they're very very big
um
media outlet in in the us and
we noticed that our ads are functioning
very well because we built this really
small engine that are is able to um
create something that's a bit more
personalized for the users and we
noticed at the beginning and they also
noticed it and they have asked us to
uh maybe try to build more features big
into that uh specific engine that we
have built before um and we've done that
and we very quickly realized that we
have something very major here because
we found out that the entire industry of
ads is not focused on user experiences
not focused on the quality of the of the
ad itself who's viewing the ad for how
many seconds reviewing it and this
entire thing was really neglected by a
lot of publishers where advertisers were
still looking for that you know high
quality paying high grade ads they don't
let their ads just be shown at the
bottom of the page where two users a day
maybe view their ads they want to have
their ads viewed by the same times
publishers want their ads to be
non-intrusive and
a good experience that users enjoy
reading content and we were able to
mitigate that gap very quickly using our
technology and then very quickly we just
brought in a team of engineers and data
scientists and start building our engine
and neglect completely you know the ad
business um and that was the public
where things started to be much more fun
because we moved from
a company doesn't care a lot about other
than advertising to a company that
actually cares about product and about
technology and i'm a product person i'm
a technology person um originally so for
me it was a very natural thing to do and
it was exciting suddenly we were excited
about launches suddenly clients are
staying longer and suddenly we're
developing features that are actually
contributing something in and
and that was about you know three and a
half years ago in
history now we're building what we're
building again
tell me a little bit about yourself
what has your journey been like you're
obviously so excited about what you're
doing you're you're even i think i i
hear even more excitement about you know
the progress and
the the team building part of it and
even more so than what the company's
actually doing even though a lot of
excitement there as well tell me how how
this whole this whole thing fits into
your own journey
um so i have a very interesting journey
journey i think uh so i was uh in uh one
of my time united 8200 in
europe
in the idf in the israel military um and
obviously that opens out of doors so
when i was um out of the army uh it was
2014 i immediately started working at
this ad tech company back then um and i
was starting as a junior developer
whatever qa doing you know a lot of just
technical things employee number 130 the
company and i immediately love what i
what i've done but i always had this
appeal of doing bigger and stronger
things and and i had plans to
you know go travel like everybody does
and go you know have other plans and um
and go study and and get educated in in
higher degree and i ended up doing none
of that and
i met those two guys where we started
browsing from and then we started this
you know insane journey back in in
2017 2016 2017 uh and ever since it's
just uh it's a snowball and you know you
said i'm excited about i mean i am
excited about the progress that we have
made because doing things like this
conversation right now makes me look
back and think about the problem
something that you never get to do yeah
right when you're you're just running
around all day um so yeah i'm pretty
excited about the progress that we've
made specifically in the last year and a
half uh which has been amazing for us as
a company um i never got to travel
though i never got to go to this big
trip after you go from the army i i have
a degree that i haven't able to complete
in in you know computer science and
economics and never finished
um i had plans to do a lot of things um
and i've done none of them because i was
so invested in my company on one hand on
the other hand it's been such an amazing
journey and
and you know i looked at my calendar
nowadays which is like packed with
meetings and and things to do all day
and then even at every evening i i get
together with people from my company you
get drinks with your vpr d and night out
of those guys
and you know i might have given up some
other things in my life which is you
know always a trade-off but i
i gained so much you know i learned so
much but also met so many people that
are just amazing i just love
you know being with them i i i love
coming to work i hate to work hybrid
because i love seeing the people i'm
working with i love the people that i am
with and i think this is the maybe the
biggest part of what i've been doing
incredible now 29 years old managing
yeah quite a big operation yeah yeah
tell me a little bit about
how you know pretty quickly you have to
adapt to
you know running a ship
not just a small team
right so i think that i haven't stopped
even being clearly honest
i i i did not fill it up it's you know
you gotta be honest in those kind of
things and then a year ago a year and a
year two months ago when i when i became
the ceo i was the product leader of the
company before and i became the ceo a
year and a half ago i um
i kind of like focused mostly on
building the product and building the
sales operation and doing this and doing
that i wasn't really focusing on midge
and i was just doing things i was
talking to the
you know the the the one of the junior
qa team members so i was talking to one
of the sales people personally and tell
them what to do when i was you know
going behind their managers and was
doing things that you're not supposed to
do as a leader um i wasn't giving my
company a vision i wasn't you know
driving the motivation i was just
focused on taking this huge ship and
driving it towards success and then
it took me about three to four months i
believe to understand that the most
important thing i can do is actually
lead and get everyone together and and
create a vision and and tell them okay
this is what we're planning to do not
next month but in a year time from now
um
and and still to this day i'm i'm
failing sometimes i mean i'm feeling a
lot actually in in being able to
to manage and being able to tell them
okay guys this is
you know what we are trying to achieve
in the long run this is why a same
client that fails maybe is not the most
important thing and this is why you
should not take those things personally
because you know back in those days a
client would pay me 500 a month which is
very small for us we would give a lot of
attention to we would really focus on
that client and enjoy you know doing
their work but also be very frustrated
when those clients are not
you know working with us properly and
and and we were you know spending time
we were utilizing resources improperly
because we couldn't be the i couldn't be
the leader and now it's very useful to
say no this is not important that's
what's important this is what we're
going towards this is what we're trying
to achieve eventually and those small
stones are small you know hurdles in in
in the meantime they don't matter we
will get to our
new vision where we will get to our goal
eventually it would just take more time
maybe and and then learning work um and
yeah being 29 is maybe one of the best
things ever to do that because i'm young
i'm
i'm single i have no kids you know it's
very easy to do that on one hand on the
other hand um it's it's very hard
because i'm
ninety percent of the people that i
manage are older than me you know my vpn
is is 40 my co-founder is 42. um but i
think that you know a part of being
young is also
being able to say i know that i'm young
i'm not you know i'm not
actually otherwise i'm not trying to
avoid that or trying to act like i'm
older because i'm not you know i'm
um it's funny i'm still asking my dad to
help me with shorts you know even my
money my position i'm still asking him
to involve the small things that i have
no idea how to do right right you manage
payrolls and clients and technology and
bringing change to the world yet when it
comes to
these different life lessons that we
need like by getting car insurance or
buying home insurance or like okay what
do what do i do now how do i go to the
bank how do they get an appointment
they're gonna help me
dad they're gonna help i love that yeah
you have no idea
yeah so what have you found itself most
helpful in your own leadership journey
because obviously you're one of the
things that i'm most impressed by is the
intentionality that you bring to the
position right you're you're you're in
one hand yeah i think you're very
thankful for the experience
and for the learning opportunities and
the other end you're very intentional
with the way that you're
you know you're going about it getting
feedback improving knowing what your
limits are knowing how people may
perceive you not avoiding it what have
you found most helpful in your own
journey and in sort of incremental
improvements on your own leadership
so i think there's two things that i've
set myself as goals maybe during the
that that growing as a leader as as as
the manager um the first thing is that i
feel like you always know
uh what is the right decision to make
and it's all about decision right i mean
we're getting decisions all day long
you're sitting in sales meeting together
decisions sitting on a
road map prioritization meeting and you
need to get a decision there's a lot of
decision needs to be made you probably
make 100 you as well you make 100
decisions a day 200 decisions per day
and you usually know
in your gut what is the right decision
to make
and the problem is that that sometimes
this right decision needs to go for a
lot of
processing chain of thought to make it
you know happen and to understand this
is the right thing that you want to do
so one of the things that i've learned
is not just to go through that gut
feeling just to yell out what i whatever
make the decision i'll make everyone
just do what i wanted them to do even if
eventually we're gonna get this still
the same decision that i wanted to be in
the first place i'm letting my team
get a decision by themselves i i will
steer them i will lead them i will try
to convince them that that what i think
is the best but eventually they're gonna
have to decide and nothing to decide for
my managers is maybe the most important
thing that i've done over the past six
seven months to understand that they
need to decide themselves and they will
be wrong
they would make mistakes and i know that
um but they still would have to make
those mistakes themselves i think the
second thing that i always felt like is
that um
[Music]
it's uh it's fine
it's fun to let go of things uh
you think that this is
this is maybe i can feel the i can feel
the challenge of that statement yeah i i
could see it in your eyes for whoever is
not watching but listening
oh my god yes mine my team's a
they don't know what you are letting go
of they don't know how you're holding
yourself back
yeah there you go you're right about
that
um i i think that uh the most important
thing is to let go of a lot of things
that that needs to be left go
specifically clients that we need to
really say that they're not the right
clients for us um employees that are not
good enough for our company it's very
hard because you love those people um
and usually you even love people that
are not good for your organization but
sometimes you have to let go of people
that are driving you
now driving you forward and then and
holding you back
um letting go of uh mistakes you have
made
because it happens in just a second ago
i was talking about those decisions and
most of the time you know what the right
decision is and maybe if you think you
know it it's not going to be the right
decision all the time right so you're
going to have to eventually be able to
you know
own your mistakes and let go let go you
you you were wrong let's see how we can
fix that that's
not try not to dwell back on those
mistakes um
i do try to learn from those mistakes i
i think that's a huge thing um i think i
was told before we started is that i was
having a really interesting conversation
with my girlfriend last night i was
telling her you know
um i'll tell you about when i'm gonna do
this this podcast and it's about leaders
and she
you know was was on despite kind of like
trying to annoy me and say are you a
leader um
and it was she was mr classic about that
and i was like you know what the truth
is i'm not sure about that
um because what makes you a leader
that's maybe the biggest question that
that i'm asking myself and out of this
conversation between me and her late
last night um one of the things that
that that we eventually got out with is
that the fact that not all leaders and
not all managers you know work well with
all the employees in all people
and a part of that is
maybe to understand that um the people
that you're working with need to also
understand who they're working with as
well and this is a huge part of it and
my management style doesn't work for
everyone and this is fun and and other
people still doesn't work for me which
is again fun we have to be able to do
this
understanding to be able to
to
let go of those people and let go of
those you know ways of management that
that are not feeding us just because
other people are you know asking us to
do that
i know this was an interesting
conversation flight
this
again going back to the intentionality
29 years old i mean i'm i'm 26 i i have
way more to learn you know it sounds
like you're you're already
but but i i don't know many 29 year olds
who get to be asking themselves
and their significant others these
questions you know as sort of the late
night conversation
it's been i think it's pretty tremendous
because
you know
you're gonna have so many more years of
being a leader and whatever you're doing
and it sounds like this is ingrained in
who you are and so i think that what i'm
getting excited and inspired by here is
not just the awesome company that you're
building and the innovativeness behind
behind your solutions which is pretty
cool but but what's really cool is sort
of these questions that you're asking
and the fact that you're holding
yourself accountable to how how are you
leading yourself your team
your employees the clients and i think
that's really the big lesson that i'm
taking here is is asking these questions
there's imperfection forever
but but being able to
hold yourself accountable
across 360 degrees you know they tell us
in the army 360 degree leadership 360.
pretty
exactly assaf thank you so much this was
awesome i really appreciate your time
michael for the opportunity thank you so
much for for having me here it was a
pleasure really getting to know uh how
we do it behind the scenes
thank you
you